live
okay for people joining this live stream
we are
doing some design reviews for the
upcoming version of language
um and this morning we are starting off
with some machine learning
capabilities uh so
let's get down to business what's first
what is this book huh
that would be what i would assume it's
uh no done
not that bad as good as any
okay picture extractor so okay so now
this one has no documentation this is
just going to be
uh so indeed uh unique expression
are going features are going to be
extracted from generic expression but
there won't be
a named feature extractor so this is
something that
you know uh won't be documented
so i'm sorry i don't understand this i
mean so a feature extractor if i just
give
a generic expression we think we have a
way of picking out features relevant for
a neural net for that is that right is
that what you're saying yes
yes and any any machine learning
subsequent task
and well i understand but but so that
seems a challenging thing because an
expression can represent absolutely
anything
and what are the important features
seems hard to know
yes so what are we doing there
so you know the idea is to extract
sequences
from from the tree uh
including several sequence there may be
some more complex stuff i haven't
finished
the development of that but for sure in
terms of design it's not something that
we can it's going to be part of the
numeric um
okay but to me look there's a lot of
arbitrariness in the way this is done
and to me we've got to be able to name
the feature extractor
so this is you know the version one tree
extractor
or maybe not version one but some name
that characterizes what this particular
tree you know what this particular
experiment is
yes it's true it's true we could do that
we need to do that
so i think what we should do is say you
know if it has a particular strategy try
and
succinctly name the strategy and call it
the blah blah blah
you know feature extractor for
expressions
um yeah i mean
and in terms of what strategies are
right i mean it really depends so much
on what the expressions mean i mean if
the expression
represents a piece of graphics then
obviously
that's a completely different feature
extractor from an expression
representing a program
does the feature extractor actually i
mean i assume if
an audio is also an expression but we
have dedicated
feature extractors exactly so it's for
expression that i'm not recognized
as a known feature type
right so it could be i mean graphic
would already be handled by
images okay you would write
all right so so but but it's a none of
the above
expression uh feature extractor okay
but can we characterize what are some
examples of none of the above
expressions
i mean in a sense they're always it's
going to be temporary because
can you describe what it does again at
the end because it sounds to me like it
views it as a tree
it's sort of a tree oriented
view of expression each expression is a
tree
so one thing i mean it's not it's not
finished but without sort of semantic
meaning
basically uh
[Music]
yeah so you can you can you can traverse
this tree in a given direction
and produce a long sequence or you can
have several sequences
um where where like what one one way is
to do random
uh work in the in the tree i mean going
down randomly
and this produces one sequence and you
do it again you have another sequence
that's that's some ways to extract um
features okay but hold on sorry so first
point is
you know we have the new trees framework
coming and
we have traversal order a bunch of
traversal order control for that
in fact we're planning general traversal
order control even for things like map
but if what you're doing is serializing
a tree effectively
then you've got different strategies you
know depth first breadth first
everything in between right and that
that
and you're basically describing this it
sounds like as a thing like that you're
sequentifying the tree
yes okay yes yes
and it's a last resort it's because
right now when there's a
uh a feature that we don't understand
the type we just say it's nominal
so it's like so it's a next step so
it's true we could already have a named
feature extractor that does that but
i don't know i thought it was more of an
internal thing that we tried to improve
improve improve
and uh yeah and as you say little by
little
some type we did not understand before
we will understand them and treat them
separately
uh yeah so i don't think that's a big
deal like i
mean we could we could have a name thing
already but
it's typically it's for very nested
expression like secret
but i think you can't no i mean so this
is a serialization
of a tree structure okay so
then what we've got to do
[Music]
is um
uh
i mean i i think it should have some
traversal order option or something
but i think you should ask i mean the
people who are working on trees namely
ian and so on
i think we should take whatever they're
doing
as ways of serializing trees and offer
those things
because they also deal with you know
heads and do you go into the head
how deeply do you nest inside the head
et cetera et cetera et cetera do you
pick the head before you pick the
arguments
all those kinds of things am i making
sense
yeah yeah usually serializing is a bit
different though because it's only about
keeping information
what there we want to have like you know
most of the meaning preserved
well i know but since we don't know what
the meaning is it's tough to know how to
preserve it
it's yeah yeah but now i mean if if
there's a way
to take a tree
and well okay so look
in the end it's going to be turned into
a neural net friendly you know neural
net friendly food
which is essentially a raise yes
okay so how do you model a tree with a
raise
well you know there are variety of ways
to do it you can write it out in
essentially full form with brackets
i mean you could write out something
that has those kinds of things you could
write out
i mean is that what in what form will it
be fed to the neural net is it purely an
array or
something else i think it's going to be
a sequence of
vectors okay
but then so look what we need to do is
inventory what those possible
you know what could be in those vectors
right because like like for example if
we have
composite heads and then arguments
like yeah i mean this seems like a
i don't think it's it's something we
should document now this is something
we're going to experiment on that's
something we're going to improve
i'm going to do a first version put some
ideas
it's going to okay but then so so what
so what's the discussion here i mean
this is
is this something can we put this
feature extractor into the neural net
repository
can we put several choices of it into
the neural net repository
repository i don't know uh that's what
i'm asking i mean
can't we isn't this isn't this a modular
thing that could be put in the
repository
so it would be to be part of feature
extra if if we want to
have the user control this it will be in
feature extraction and in the encoder so
that's related to the second
uh item uh and then and then they could
be
ways to to control the method yes uh
but for now i don't think yeah i don't
think that's something we should discuss
much it's it's going to be some internal
thing it's going to be something we
have so i don't understand i understand
that somebody gives us
an expression which which you know
they're pieces which we understand
images audio yes yes yes you know blah
blah blah we understand all that stuff
okay there's wrapping all those sub
pieces
general expressions that we do not
understand yeah
they will see which expression we don't
understand
so when you do the model then you can
get with information
and even write on the visualization of
the model it shows
the interpretation of features so it
will say image text
you know nominal blah blah blah they
might see something
expression and i'll say okay well this
hasn't been understood as a classic type
and then it tried to do something on
this expression
that's the way it works currently
so we have kind of the feature types
that are that are documented
and
which user can control as well with the
feature type option so there will be a
new feature type which would be
expression
right so actually yeah this will be
documented there will be a new feature
type
expression
well i'm sorry so
okay
um
okay
so
ethan is commenting that he hopes that
you map will be a feature extraction
method
it's on our calendar it's uh on our
camera on our
item list of things to do
but uh not for this version next one
pretty sure it's gonna be in
so there are suggestions on the live
stream about
um dealing with hierarchical
you know dealing with html and things
like this
yeah i mean i don't think
i mean that's what this is relevant for
right but i mean that's not
our type of expression so that's again
yet a different kind of thing you know
like html
there are presumably pieces of html that
one cares i mean i don't even know where
the formatted text is something for
which there is a good
uh feature extractor is there
what text formatted text
text which has you know headings and
this and that and the other
you know what are the feature extractors
for that yeah no i don't think we will
understand them
no i understand we don't but we could
use a box structure
and send that to expression feature
extractor we could
yes we could as a zero level
approximation
well i i know but you know our notebook
for example we what is the feature
extractor for a notebook
i don't think we've thought about this
properly and
[Music]
you know well first maybe we need some
uh applications for the
do you want to classify the content for
example the topic
i know i know i know that's a that's a
yes that's a good question and that's
why i'm also concerned about this
general expression thing
because i think without knowing anything
it's tough to know you know to go
anywhere
but i mean we're not what does it do
right now with general expressions
it does i mean it assumes that there are
nominal values
abc
so it doesn't go inside at all no not at
all so
it was the idea was just the next step
like it's a small project you know
it's first on the end fair enough fair
enough okay so
all right so we're just we're just
trying to go inside at all and then
a separate project is to study it's a
good topic
for um uh be a good topic for
summer school projects and things like
that to study different expression
encoders
yeah yeah yeah definitely i'm going to
add that to my
list here hold on one second since i
don't think we have a project manager in
this meeting is that correct
um
[Music]
let's see uh
[Music]
okay all right onward
okay what's the next thing here
it's uh project extraction uh just
before
feature extraction as net encoder so
now uh it's documented and jerome did it
actually
implemented it you can use a feature
extractor function
inside the network that's nice at the
place of the
to encoder and also you can learn
a feature extractor
just before the training when you do
netrain of a net
and if in place of the net encoder you
put
a feature extraction method like
standardize
or you know bp encode whatever
uh it will learn this extractor and then
and then include it in the network
so there's there's the documentation
page if you want to look it's just the
feature extractor
uh i forgot how it's called feature
extra
okay do we have jerome here uh no
let's catch our own please just if you
look at that encoder it's gonna be in
okay we gotta not do these meetings
without the people who wrote the code
okay that's true
yeah which one am i looking at i think
then you can see that it's a new uh
and then you can see the feature
extractor 12.3
so it's a new type of net encoder which
use feature extraction underneath
okay so wait a minute so so in that case
how are you giving
the feature extractor you've got to give
the name of the feature extractor right
yes where do you go do that
so if you click what should i do
click feature extractor the string it
will open
the page dedicated to this specific net
encoder
and uh then you can say an encoder
feature extractor comma
f and you put a few tricks sort of
function or you can just put
feature extractor by itself and it will
figure it out how to extract features
uh or you put the method as a
you know second argument of the list and
we also added as kind of syntactic sugar
you can also just directly put a feature
extractor function
uh inside the network
looks nice i don't really understand
this encoder automatically learned
during that training
explain um so this
it will so you don't you don't give a
feature extra function right
so it just transforms to as you say
something that can be understood by by a
neural network
yeah what's the raw material what what
raw neural net is it training then
so this you include inside the network
right
yes goes inside the network and this
network goes inside the train
and so the data that is inside nitrane
is going to
be used by the feature to learn a
feature extractor
by the way i think jerome is here so
maybe
i don't quite understand that we've got
some network
usually there's an appendage which is
the feature extractor
but here you're saying there's no
appendage is that correct
i mean there is a hey what layers i mean
are there weights that are being learnt
in this feature extractor okay so of
weights of
what for example the
sterilization i mean it depends on your
data
i understand but i'm asking the question
if you put in
a net you know this feature extractor
net encoder piece
okay in a network yes what additional
weights
are being what new degrees of freedom
are there being added that are then
going to be trained
okay it's a separate training so it's
not part of the network
so it's it's when you do net train
the first thing it does it learns the
feature extractor
completely independently of the rest and
what controls are there on that i mean
like how many rounds of training does it
do what is it you know
well it does not because it use feature
extraction which is just
yeah it's just and i think the easiest
thing to say is that this is completely
equivalent
as doing feature extraction on your data
set and then taking the result
and using it in the network okay fine
this is
in one go basically instead of you doing
two things the two steps
you do it in one step and what about
future extraction how do they get
fed through through this method the
third line
of usage third year's line feature
extractor method
so you can specify standardized vector
indicator
okay what about the options uh there's
no options
for feature extraction is that right
it's just
it has okay it depends what we talk
about
uh like
there is a plan to have an option
related to the extraction method
which is not there yet but
it's true that there is
there are all kinds of random seeding is
an option all kinds of random exactly
yeah
there is this and this it's true we have
no control over
well this is also more of a convenience
and the main way to do that yeah
i mean well i can always do it do it
separately and set whatever you want
i understand that but i'm asking the
question i mean
so what are we adding here so it's the
ability to put a feature extraction
output inside a network or what yes
that's the main thing the feature
extractor function you can put it in
your network
that's the main thing okay so that's the
primary thing to document then
because it seems like these these cheap
approaches
may be fine until they're not fine and
then it has to be said in this
documentation
that you have to go to this full form if
you if you need to
yeah right yeah yeah we could clarify it
it is the first usage
to i mean the one that we advertise the
most
okay yeah we could be we could be we're
only on item two we've got a lot of
items to go through
let's uh so yeah classified predict
uh sharp feature explanation something
we talked already
you can open classifier function that
would be one way to
to to see it then copy paste it in other
places
so basically it's a new property of the
classifier function you see these sharp
values
12.3 plus yep and
we decided originally we had two
properties sharp values and
interventional sharp values
and now we decided to have only one and
you can through missing imputation
missing value synthesis which we should
talk right after
it's very very connected okay so what
does it basically return
so this returns um
something that has the same shape as
your input data
you input examples but instead of the
variable values you have the feature
uh sharply you have the sharply values
so
it's the same size as all of your
examples are the same size as one of
your examples
it it's independent for each example so
let's say you just give one example to
your classifier to return something that
are the same shape
and but instead you have the sharply
value inside
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
this is when you say example
the thing is trained and now for this
particular
instance yes it's telling you exactly
it gives you the explanation the
contribution
of each feature to the result well i
this is a completely obscure piece of
documentation
this is utterly obscure piece of
documentation
what this should say is okay
so most of these things are giving you
in most cases probabilities
in the classifier function will return
you know some list of possible
classified things in each case their
probability
what this is returning if i'm trying to
understand it
is
i see i see i see for each but you
shouldn't say example
sorry about calling them yeah no no okay
okay it was a copy paste from classified
measurements
where it made sense in that context yeah
you should remove you know i will remove
for each example
you separated the future explanations
yeah right
we we first did it for classifier
measurements right and obviously you've
got to give some examples here
in this of course in the documentation
but but then
and so what's the normalization of these
values
so they sum let's say for predict
the sum of all these values are the
difference between the mean
uh value in the training sets and the
prediction
to be simple they sum to the prediction
for predict
and for classified something different
but so for classify
you know you've got a dog a picture of a
dog
and it's got so let me understand what
this does for an image for example
okay so for an image do you get an image
for the shot values
no it would be to be an array we won't
support her image for the first uh
version
uh but it will be an array that has a
size and we talked about it at first we
wanted to return an image
and then we like was kind of crazy for
various reasons
so so it's going to be an array the same
size the internal array that is in the
image
and give all the sharp values for every
pixels
basically okay
so i can just say image of that and i
will convert it to an image
yes and are the chat values always
positive or not
no it can be negative as well
that's something we already designed
together like that's that's come
was kind uh of
we document a little bit better but
the the missing thing was missing value
synthesis that's a new option
that's we should definitely talk about
okay uh
yeah i don't see it here actually you
can click it you can click it
i don't see it here where is it sharp
values i said the contribution like
12.3 you can say missing value synthesis
i'm sorry where what oh there yeah yeah
there yeah but i don't understand
why isn't that documented yeah i have to
put it yeah we didn't put it
we didn't put it and uh yeah is somebody
taking notes here
no okay we're going to need in these in
these meetings going forward
roger we're going to need some somebody
who's able to take notes
roger yeah but don't
don't you usually have someone that from
no but we specifically you specifically
don't have project managers
so we haven't brought project managers
in here
so we're going to have to install but in
previous meetings you've had someone
that then sends out notes
has that changed well but they've been
the project manager
for the project but you don't have
project managers for your projects
um so where can i get someone that takes
notes i don't know
i don't haven't you asked why don't you
ask
why don't you ask danielle isn't devin
doing something for machine learning
of course of course devin what am i
thinking
there's gonna be somebody for each of
these meetings okay so yeah
okay so yeah davin should be there well
maybe he should come now
okay
okay
p winkler on our live stream is
commenting that classifier with tree
methods is not working for batch
prediction
which batch production is useful because
it's faster is this going to be fixed
what doesn't work with batch position it
says classify with tree methods
oh surprised
i i think it worked by much i think it's
paralyzed
but i should should double check who's
who's
who would be the relevant person for
that it's me
okay me timothy is big new i think he
worked on that as well
okay we should double check but i think
it's like for ronald for us and stuff
it's definitely
uh parallel parallelized
okay all right so there's if that's not
working it's a bug
okay missing value synthesis okay
option to control how to impute missing
value
in everywhere classify
predict everywhere
okay so what we've called
the main function that does this is what
is it called now
synthesize missing values okay you can
see it actually on the
first paragraph okay
so what is this defining this is
defining the method for missing value
synthesis
yes yes i mean method and strategy as we
call it so you can either
control something several things you can
do uh you can put
a learn distribution in it something
that that you
you know you trained separately then you
can also put
the method of then distribution like
multinormal or
kindle density estimation and also
there's another type of things
that we call strategy which is
once you have this distribution do you
find
the most likely value or do you sample
one value you know condition on the
known values
so if you scroll down
so you see so you have you have possible
methods this is a method of land
distribution
and then you have possible strategy
which is random sampling marginal
sampling or mold finding
why is it mode finding i mean why isn't
it just you using the mode
i mean in other words the question is
what do you put in for the missing value
that's the basic question right yes
right so the missing value is going to
be filled in with something
yeah we don't know the modes that's why
it's it's an approximation it's going to
try to find the mode
and i understand but but why isn't it
called mode approximation i mean
as opposed to i mean why isn't it called
random sample marginal sample
mode approximation or something because
these are the things you fill in
because it's a strategy uh that's
something that we already
that's something that we already
discussed in synthesized missing values
so
only marginal sampling is new
synthesized using values already have
random sampling and mode finding
okay all right okay so but the name of
this option
it bothers me that this is too similar
i mean i mean this is basically what to
do with missing values
um kind of which by the way we already
have a lot of these
options and that's a bit annoying but
well
right missing behavior there's but
they're used in such different contexts
and for
you know that so what are those options
i think if you scroll down in a c also i
put them
you can see missing behavior missing
data rules
okay that's the two things that's two
things missing there are rules and
missing behavior
you know option for semantic import that
are this i mean it's completely
different
what should be considered missing and
what to replace it with
that's a good question what should be
considered missing
this is missing pattern we have missing
pattern
that that solves that
basically explain what should be okay
all right fine so if it's 999 is the way
you represent missing data
yes and that can be used in missing
value pattern
this is missing behavior right after
missing data rules
yes which i forgot what it does but it's
pretty different as well
yeah option for query oh no this is a
mess
so these all need to be brought together
so i mean missing behavior
well whatever happens this is going to
be an experimental thing
because we're not ready for this i mean
you know we've got many different
functions which have to do with missing
data
from things like around to things like
semantic imports to things
all kinds of things there yeah and what
this is doing
is saying one of the possible strategies
is you make it up
right you make up data and that possible
strategy could be used in other places
as well
right there's no reason why in that uh
data set query business
you know it's a little bit scary and i
hate to think people would use that for
some but you know that's a standard
statistical method
of you know you just make up extra data
am i making sense and there's no reason
why we shouldn't support that
in fact using these exact same methods
and functions
did you also look into missing data
method that's another one
that we have i believe only used in
time series and co okay so what a total
mess
okay so look let's do the following
let's get a separate meeting for all of
these missing functions
okay we inventory all of them get
everybody who's involved with all of
them
and let's try and grind through which
what we do with them
oh there you go what's that yeah this
one is i
miss that one it's pretty similar right
so missing data method seems like a good
thing to try to use for uh
i mean this is a this is a total mess
missing data rules is the same thing as
missing value pattern i think
what to replace it with yeah i mean
guys we need to have a separate meeting
can we put this in lcc devon is here
maybe yeah
yeah this is okay but then it's going to
take over an hcc meeting this will this
will be a
whole meeting and separate
all right but for your purposes here
i don't understand why you can't use
missing data method for this
yes yes it will be
yes let's see
the missing data methods the methods
seem to rely on the fact that it is a
sequence so all the methods are related
to interpolation
oh what is the method it doesn't even
say what the methods are here where are
the methods here
no i think you can you just can scroll
down to excel
that's not good enough i mean so this
documentation is clearly inadequate
right because if it doesn't say at the
top it effectively isn't here
uh it's in options okay that's not good
enough that's not what we do
but if this is a generic
yeah if it's a generic option why not if
it's if it can be used no i understand
that but
roger is saying we don't have to
document what the possible values for
name are
and he's wrong about that right it's not
good enough to document the
examples yeah but we have many cases
okay this is where you're wrong where
you cannot document it globally because
we don't have an
object-oriented document system no i i
understand that okay
that means that there needs to be method
specific settings
for individual functions it cannot be
for that so
it shouldn't be okay then then we should
have a separate discussion about this
because i think we're dealing with that
by primarily by these
ways of having separate documentation
pages for named objects
like this but let's okay that's a
separate discussion
which should have been in the monthly
documentation meeting because i think
this is
if that's really the issue then let's
break off yet a separate meeting for
that
okay about documenting things where
the possible names the possible values
for an option
are different for different functions
right that's the issue you're describing
yes right so let's let's break off a
separate discussion about that
okay what we should do with that right
[Music]
um however for this
yeah one thing i liked is that it's it's
yeah it's really related to
the silencing values i don't care i mean
we've got like eight
different options yeah no no i i i agree
i agree it's
sometimes it's hard to package all that
together as well
look if you need it for this version
make an experimental function we will
clean it up later
all right all right i would just call it
missing value synthesis method
it's uh yeah but then inside you have
method strategy
uh all right okay all right missing
value synthesis then
but let's let's make sure you know
experimental and we will join all that
yeah i agree
but it looks like we've got five or six
functions which are all circling around
the same
question of handling missing data which
we know is an issue because it's also an
issue for statistics
functions and so on right
yeah definitely yeah that will require
some good design but
i think the results will be good right
some hard design but then the reason
might be good okay so
p went close saying gradient boosted
trees random forest gives wrong results
for even the same point when doing batch
predictions see red minus two number
945.
so devin that's something for you to go
chase down okay
ethan is complaining that synthesize
missing values doesn't work on images
bigger than thumbnails
or anybody else yeah and that's a
feature extraction
issue i mean this learn the distribution
of images and learning the description
of images is something that is super
hard
and uh so we need to do some transfer
learning to
to so so it works on reasonable small
amount of images
and we haven't we haven't nailed it yet
like that's a hard problem it's actually
a hard
research problem how to do efficient
um transfer learning for for learning
generative model images it's uh we had
one idea there was an
antenna working on a specific problem uh
but it didn't work out it was too hard
the experiments were too difficult to
carry
okay but i don't think we have a
solution anytime soon
nathan is commenting yesterday he
trained a gpt style network take strings
images category
generate text summaries which we don't
seem to be able to do yet
i don't know i don't know what's
involved in doing that
so that's i mean yeah that's massive
massive massive models
uh train on even more massive amount of
data
and uh
yeah we eventually we could have
it will not be in a repository this
cannot fit people cannot download such
things
how do they get they cannot run it i
mean they run it through an api like
gpt3
no one else and open ai has gpt3 they
have an api that you can you know
access you know i mean it's probably use
i don't know how many gpus just to run
the model
well presumably microsoft has one in
azure too
exactly maybe there's one in azure
exactly and they probably you know
sent it on a hard disk or something
right so i mean if that's the future of
you know
we'll do feature extraction and these
sort of things you know through
something hosted in our cloud
but we have gpt2 on the repository
that you can use already how big are
these big models
how big are the ones that are just
sitting on on centralized clouds
i'm gonna check uh
i think i mean that's certainly an
interesting
scenario that i'm not sure
um it's an interesting scenario so
175 billions of parameters
okay but that's but i mean that's so
that's a few hundred gigabytes
uh billions it's 700 gigabytes
that sounds about right i mean if if
that doubles you know
reaching the terabyte model but to run
okay ethan is commenting you can
download gpt2 medium
and run it on a 16 gigabyte gpu
do we have gp2 we have tpg-2 we have
gpt2
uh i'm not sure if you have all the
version you can check in the repository
okay uh
[Music]
gp2 transformer train on webtex data
anything is commenting on new
architectural pieces like transgan
assemble resnet okay these are not ones
i've yet heard of
but i do think that sort of strategy
wise
this is an interesting question because
you know is the future so two things
seem to be happening smaller networks
and larger networks
that's my impression at least am i right
am i wrong
i mean i don't know if small network is
happening
like for images it doesn't increase so
much
the size of the network small networks
still do a good job for texts they're
getting
absolutely massive okay but hold on hold
on because
my understanding is like our facial
feature recognizer went
down in size dramatically am i right
well yes i retrain with a much newer
architecture that was optimized for
exact size
yeah but this is not always the case i
was trying to find actually if
um give me a second the the
new family of the detector by by google
the efficient that
it's they scale not just the input size
of the image
but they scale the whole architecture
across a line
so they increase the depth they increase
the number of filters they increase
everything
of course the last one it takes like uh
10 seconds on my laptop well the first
one is
half a second and this because has a lot
more parameters
right but so so i'm just trying to
understand the
strategic future of these things right
is it going to be the case
so that's a that's a possible model
where you say
i mean it's like doing you know finite
elements or something or doing any of
these things you can say
well i'm just going to use more data
points and then it'll take longer and be
bigger
right so my question is is that the
future of these kinds of things that you
can just say
i'm going to you know for this problem
and for this set of computer resources i
have these
i'm going to use this kind of network
and then maybe i'm going to use the
bigger network
you know the more finite elements or
whatever in a case where i want higher
fidelity or i'm prepared to spend more
computer time
is that is that the future of this of
this area or what
i i think that we haven't reached the
end in terms of
performance improvements for size
well i understand that but the question
okay look look
what's being said is but there's a
shitload of applications that don't need
any of this big stuff at all for single
processing of course
you know i know i know so there's a
front here
that's using this big stuff just like
there's going to be a frontier for
solving pdes or any of these other
things
where you're running big codes that you
know that use lots of memory and lots of
processing time so i'm trying to
understand in this space
is it the case that in those in that
case
basically there are certain kinds of pde
problems that are basically inaccessible
unless you have the the fancy
supercomputer
but many are not and so my question here
is
you know what's the story with with
these kinds of systems i mean
yeah it might be the case um
although you know that there's a lot of
efforts which is successful for image to
reduce the network that's why that
didn't grow that big so
maybe it's going to happen with text as
well then there's new hardware
that might be more adapted to these
networks
but that's a different thing that's the
same thing that's happened with linear
algebra and all these kinds of things
and that's you know what brought us gpus
in the first place
i mean in in okay
the issue is you're saying for images
the networks are not getting much bigger
is that the corr is that the statement
that i'm understanding yeah they they
manage i think they get
bigger but not like not big there is a
factor of 10
i just checked like between the smallest
models and the largest model
is a bit more than 10 like let's say 30.
but the the
there the push is like on one side you
want networks that are extremely small
as nappy because you want to use them on
phones for example
devices yeah image network oh now
basically all the
photography part of the phone is is a
trade-off between
taking a lot of pictures and running
neural networks on them to
optimize low light condition focus like
you you
you don't want to to rely on the camera
equipment too much
it's expensive and yeah it's not now
those are extremely fast and they're
also very very small then you have those
bigger networks that are it's
a sad thing is one day if a if a phone
camera sees anything unexpected
it'll be like the blind spot for humans
where it'll just fill it in with random
stuff i'm very worried that you know a
car is just gonna crash
into people at a carnival parade because
it's not trained on that but
let's hope not right there
well but i mean the funny thing is that
like with with our visual system right
our blind spot where the optic nerve
connects you know we just fill in
random things from from neighboring
parts of our visual field
and no doubt cameras are doing or
probably already doing the same thing
um you know if you have a spot of dust
on the lens it might just fill in
you know a random image that that uh
from
from the context but okay but but now
talk about text for a second
my impression there is the models are
getting really huge
yeah yeah but do we understand why and
do we understand whether that's going to
continue
it's i mean clearly the corpus the
corpora
there is a bound on the size of the
corpora
i mean probably a much smaller bound the
amount of text that's been written in
the world is much smaller than the
number of pixels of images that have
been taken
right and
so my question go ahead it carries more
information on the text though
i would say i also think it's a problem
of
redundancy like you can alter a picture
of a dog in very much sure right
the compression ratios for images are
like factor of 100 the compression ratio
of the text
might be 50 it can be even more i mean
if you know the data set
you can compress i mean how big are
those image feature vectors
maybe a thousand elements and that can
work for a
if you have a single object in the image
can work for an image which is a
thousand per thousand
right right right well that's why people
were trying to make up meaning vectors
for
text which hasn't worked all that well
right turns out the set of things people
want to say i mean
it's not surprising there are many more
sentences a combinatorial
whereas you know nouns the number of
nouns
is you know a fixed number like five
thousand in english or something
um okay so
there's questions here for about
convolutional auto encoders for image
feature extraction
is that something that we have
um actually
no no amir did
for sequence like recurrent auto encoder
i don't think it do convolution okay so
ethan is complaining that training
object detectors
we are working on training object
detectors that's something that is
coming and it's going to be very nice
simple high-resolution gan
i'm not sure so sure about that i mean
we can do that but it's a little bit of
a mess
and it's always a bit of a mess isn't it
to train guns yes yeah it's harder than
than
regular that's for sure
um okay let's just i'm i'm running into
my next meeting here but let's keep
going for a little while here
so um since it's similar topic
i mean similar topic yeah recalibration
function you could look at this
documentation page
and this is uh something we already
discussed some time ago
so i think design wise we are in sync
and we agreed and yes i remember this
issue yeah
yeah so ideas for both classify and
predict you can put a function
or specify if you want
i i remember yeah i mean this is a bit
of a complicated concept but i think we
managed to grind it to the point where
it's somewhat usable
yeah yeah
okay let's go take a quick look through
the rest of this
okay you're on that supporting video
in the net encoder so is that something
that's now done
no it's ongoing
we're well we're planning to have it in
property
okay and is it going to be so so
then what will happen is i mean how big
are the things that come out of a video
so let's say i have a minute of video
what do i expect to be the result of the
net encoder
it depends on how you constructed the
net encoder and what parameters you're
passing it
it could either be all of the frames or
it could be a sequence of a
set number of frames for example
it's not something that gives the
overall flow with the frames i mean it
is a frame by frame
pretty dumb extractor in the sense they
just extracts frames
and passes them to the neural network
and then the neural network will
eventually do whatever
complicated but so there's nothing that
is
the analog i mean there's nothing that's
using
the basically space-time structure of
the thing it's just using
just this the fact that it is a sequence
of frames
then the network will be in charge of
interpreting that as
and there are no net encoders that go
across something like mp4 or something
would go
would would use the temporal dimension
in its encoding of things in its
compression right it's using the fact
that the frames don't differ very much
but you're saying that for neural nets
there isn't a way of doing that encoding
that can
similarly take advantage of the fact
that frames don't differ much i am not
aware of any uh
the net encoders for video that we've
looked at all treat the input as
uh sequences of images
hd what is this
code depicts i think okay so this is
i mean that's an interesting question is
these networks that are being provided
let's say by nvidia what i mean
how do we plug into those things because
you know one model of plugging into
those things
is through the neural net repository but
i don't know what the apis for those
networks are
and maybe there's an analog of service
connections for some of these
i mean there's a question right now for
some of these
for example very big networks okay for
some of these networks that are very gpu
bound
or very big and remote
what is the correct way for us to plug
into them in other words things which
for us we must treat as black boxes
how should we because right now what
we're doing is we're providing
mechanisms
to bring the network into our ecosystem
and
do things with it and be able to you
know seamlessly work with it
so the question is what if the network
is a black box of some kind
either remote or local how can we deal
with it
you mean in terms of evaluation or in
more in general more general question
well i would say evaluation would be a
good start yes
i mean if the is a black box i mean this
is tied to the to the only
evaluator i guess if it is not something
we can uh
i don't know but i don't know whether we
have a mechanism in the on even in the
current design of the onyx evaluator i
don't think
we have a mechanism to deal with a black
box
thing with a certain api you see what
i'm saying
maybe but maybe not really because it's
something very open
if i interpret it correctly is a very
very open question the api can be
completely arbitrary
i know i will throw at you a library
figure out what to do with it
without context no that's impossible
right but the point is that we can
curate for a certain fixed
set of these things we could curate just
as we do with service connections
we can curate the connect connectivity
right so the question is i mean this is
what i'm trying to understand
you know strategically where is this
field going that is
you know there are okay one thing is
there are just neural nets that we can
run in our evaluator that we can run in
our training framework
that are generically let's say onyx
compatible networks
right that's one category another
category is ones that are
you know the petabyte network the
central
you know text translation brain of the
world that nobody's going to run locally
you know that might be a direction that
things are going another possibility is
they're things then their noun isn't an
api then it's an api
right but but then and then another
thing
is the kind of it's running in some
you know funky uh special purpose
hardware thing
and you have very little access to it
other than just calling it somehow
like a like a system and then we have
our connected device framework if you
want to sort of play in
i know language yeah i know i know i
know it's not unreasonable
right i'm asking what do we you know
right now we have the neural net
repository that is a repository of local
networks
yes right just like the data repository
is a repository of great data that you
can load into the system now we are in
the process of changing that so that the
data repository
can provide the same metadata access the
same connectivity
but to data sets that can be completely
remote
or can be feeds for example right
so you know so in other words you might
have something
which you know as far as the hooking it
up
within your program it looks just like a
standard resource data object
but it's actually a petabyte in size and
it's remote
the same thing for a network then it's
we need really to think about that i
mean i know that there are services
offering that for translation for
example
but they maintain data centers in
iceland
with the with the gps yeah but some of
that is a bit overstated
but yes i mean yes this is what they
claim at least yes
it's rather overstated i mean you know
for example you know it used to be the
case that if you wanted to do voice to
text
it always had to be on a on a central
server that people said was mysteriously
large
but it turns out that's just not really
correct
right okay but i mean it's it's still a
thing that we want to
well it might be able to get i mean
it's just like we have had a service
connection for
text translation that's how it's worked
text translation is a remote api right
now for us
but it's about to be hopefully not a
remote api
right or you're going to be able to pick
something where it can be done locally
right
yep right so i mean the point that i'm
making is
strategically there's this question of
is it going to networks which are
one of three possibilities you know only
available on centralized cloud servers
ours other people's whatever only
um i mean just like you know we don't
our whole entity framework
and knowledge base that's not locally
available it's way too big
right we cache pieces of it locally but
we don't expect the whole thing and we
expect people are going to use some only
some tiny corner of it
but you know with neurons a little
different because right now in the way
neural nets are used right now
it's like it's not the case that if you
have a translation network
and you're only talking about you know
i don't know the uh um
you know the feeding habits of the
armadillo or something
that you only need to download a little
piece of the network that's about
you know words related to armadillos
right that that's not the way it works
right now whereas in our knowledge base
and entity framework
if you're only dealing with you know
properties of volcanoes in iceland
then you can get away with just cashing
properties of volcanoes in iceland
without
you know caching things about the
seismic properties of
you know the the uh such and such plate
or something
does that make sense i mean so in other
words there isn't the same kind of local
you know partial caching thing it's
either you've got the whole network or
you get none of it
and so i guess the other possibility is
that there are networks that are deeply
tied to hardware
at least at the evaluation level
and that require essentially library
type access
but a local am i getting all the cases
or are there other cases
uh i mean it seems reasonable that might
be more i
i this is what we have to think about
because if we're going to make a
strategy
right like for text translation right we
know that the strategy is basically
going to be
you can use the remote service if you
want to but you can also use
or you can i mean you know it look what
we do with entities let me remind you
is the first time you make a query it's
done remotely
what's your goal that you're making a
strategy for
how we support things to do with neural
nets to make them as useful as possible
right and so we don't get you know a
situation where people are asking us but
what about this network what about that
network
and we say we don't have a way to deal
with that well why don't we ask we don't
we have
like 50 people on here that that
come from all walks of life what are
some
modes that we don't support that we
should support sure
if people want to make comments that
will be terrific
so in any case
i mean we we do have some specific
comments here and
i'm i'm what i'm saying is
you know with text translation just to
recap
and i think this is an issue here
you know what we're saying is we're
going to have a gen you know text
translation can operate
in several modes one mode is you do an
initial text translation
and you don't want to download five
gigabytes for this initial text
translation
by default i would assume
right just like for you know looking up
you know the height of such and such a
volcano you don't want to download
you know hundreds of gigabytes of
geographic data
just for that one query it depends
stephen i mean
it's like if you have it running on a
smartphone to improve your picture
taking
as as julia pointed out you want it
i'm well aware so so roger we've this
problem is one that we have worked on
in detail for the knowledge base and
entity stuff over the last several years
right right and we have a pretty
reasonable solution there
that may not be perfect but you know it
is a mixture
of you know initial remote queries
followed by background caching followed
by
larger scale local querying right
oh is that what you is at the back of
your mind as sort of a hierarchy
or yes that's what i'm talking about yes
okay i
see right but or something where i don't
think we have enough of the pieces
well i don't think that's right i mean
we do have the pieces
we just for example for text translation
we have exactly the setup
yeah we have the two setups yes right
but it's not just two
it's not just two because there are
multiple networks that you could use
for text translation there are different
sizes different fidelities etc
am i correct guys yes
yes yes actually joffrey is going to
convert to
i mean to type one is smaller and faster
and uh yeah right so i mean
what we've done with a bunch of
functions is performance goal quality or
speed
which is just going to go down that path
it's like right that sounds like that
right so that's a perfectly reasonable
thing to do but
you know we've got this that's why i'm
trying to understand strategically
is it the case that networks this is the
question i'm asking
you know my impression is that there is
some lines of research
that are leading to bigger networks
including very big networks
and other lines that are saying let's
take this let's optimize the
architecture let's make smaller networks
right yes i think that's correct so so
our challenge
is to understand you know what do we do
in that situation so
you know the smaller networks
generically will be putable in the in
the neural net repository and
downloadable
the bigger networks will trail into
things where you can only access them
through apis
okay so the question is how do we make a
uniform interface
to all of those possibilities and that's
what we're doing with the data
repository
for you know for actual for you know for
pure data
so it's something that seems to me we
should probably use that as a model for
the neural net case
does that make sense
[Music]
yeah yeah maybe external nets might play
a role here
you know we had the idea of of having
like the onyx runtime and
and supporting our next network
without using our framework maybe
you know it could be the interface to
use external networks
that are remotely right well okay fine
but i mean
the point here is what is that interface
how is that defined like for example
for service i mean there could be an
application function like the one that
we brought up here it's like text
translation
where you can switch between modes of
course and we can automate
that with if it could be performance
goals like when is it worth
exactly taking the hit so we have
similar things
elsewhere we do just in time compilation
no of course and we've done this the
place where we've most developed this
is in the knowledge base area this
trade-off between
remote and local is most developed in
that area
right but the question is is this a
frame something we need to build for
neural nets because if you're going to
tell me
that well actually you know these giant
neural necks are just a transient phase
and in every neural net that's been
developed people eventually found a way
to compress it
then that's the thing worth knowing so
the the story
so far has been that uh
only recently with this gpt uh
it got super big and we don't know yet
if this can be
reduced but i mean the thing that you
know it's complicated is this is
interwoven with market forces
right so if i may interject uh
one scenario sure networks have been
reduced greatly
uh so that they fit in uh commercial
gpus but there are
so many machines that do not have a gpu
that is accessible by our framework
so that's a temporary that that is
hopefully a solvable you know it's a
thing that the industry is going to
solve for us so to speak
hopefully right so you know i don't
think we should plan on that direction
the question really is you know i mean
the thing that's complicated is there
are clearly market forces
that are weighted towards make the
networks incredibly big so they can only
be run by a cloud provider
right there are reasons that people you
know it's like
like there are plenty of things where
they could actually be done locally
you know even various kinds of web
search things things like that but
nobody
that's not a commercially attractive
thing for people
right so this could be the same thing
the dynamics here could be
yes you could compress these networks
but nobody really wants to do that
it's like somewhat cynically you know
why made a cheap drug when you can make
an expensive one
um but i don't know whether that's
what's going to happen
right the other possibility is that as
you've said and it's by my impression
that most forms of network they get big
and then they get small again
unless there's a fundamental reason why
that can't happen and you've made an
argument that that can't happen for
texts but i
i'm skeptical about that argument
people comment on this
okay well i guess we should wrap up here
yeah
so i was looking at a paper that was
that that whose goal was to reduce this
this uh
text big text model and pretty
successfully so i mean
i think it's not impossible
that they will manage to reduce the size
of the network and and
still have good performance right well
so so you know a model
a meta model could be people make big
things
and then within two years they're small
that has been kind of the trend uh you
know it's all
right so so if that is the trend right
then them supporting then the set of
people
who will need to use it in its big phase
is sort of the leading edge research
crowd
and that requires a different kind of
tooling
than you know if it's the case that it's
going to be permanently big
so anybody who's going to use it any
consumer who's going to use it is going
to have to do
use the big one then that's
you know that's one thing but if it's
going to be the case that within two
years everything becomes small
then it's a different set of
infrastructural needs
and it will be really useful for
planning purposes for us to be able to
understand that
right but look i i think the right thing
to do is to
allow the neural net repository to be a
gateway in the same way that the data
repository is becoming a gateway
that can access larger scale assets
that are not going to be downloaded yeah
that makes sense
and then and you know then it's a
transparent thing obviously there will
be performance issues you know you can
make a choice just like you can with
entities
you know you can either it's an
interesting question whether i don't
think we use performance goal explicitly
with like entity value we probably could
i mean it's a different type of
performance goal it's you know do you
want to
uh pay the price initially of a big
download
and then everything will be fast or do
you want to have the initial
download i mean you know we have chosen
that automatically for users because it
seems like
that's the thing you always want um
[Music]
okay okay so
okay so let's just talk about a couple
of more of these things that we need to
wrap up text cases
so this is now based on our uh
training loop between nlu and nlp is
that correct
jerome
i can answer for jerome yes yes
basically
they are doing good work um they're
going to have
data for every entity and uh
enough tag for jerome to train a new
version
so this is all entity types all entity
types supported by interpreters yes
correct so yeah so yeah the short story
that jerome in the past did a huge data
set
using wikipedia link uh um
from alpha interpreter and a bunch of
other things but the problem is that it
was
some entity had a lot of tags and some
had very little
so this is an effort to have a minimum
number of tags for every entity
uh okay but so wait a second so so these
things like geo coordinates street
addresses and so on
those are those are already taken care
of correct
look at text content okay text contents
and there should be a link to the guide
of the text content entities
by the way if devin could please report
again in this prototype build
that look at this absurd piece of
garbage that we're seeing with this
this do you see this thing
yeah it's going to work as well contents
both
both work what's that said then this
stuff takes content here you go
yeah right yeah this is it so they were
supported
but many of them were really bad because
we had a
tiny data set for them
and now this is addressing this so he's
using some
transfer learning and some bootstrapping
like i did
quite some good research to figure out
how to take maximum advantage of small
data set
and he figured that with only 20 tag
per entity he could have
pretty good result so that's that's the
the task now the the creation team is
doing 20 tag
for every of this type
okay so so if i say for example a
if i say i want to pick out all airports
exactly like probably right now it
doesn't work that well i mean airport i
don't know maybe airport works already
good now but
if you take something even more you know
random like
nuclear reactors yeah nuclear reactors
probably were very bad at it
but i mean to be good at it i mean i
have no idea how they're named but it
could be you know
s 22 or something could be a nuclear
reactor
and to know that that's a nuclear
reactor is largely a story of context
yes yes yes that's
that's why with only 20 example per type
you know by learning the context we was
able to get like 90
or something like that of accuracy and i
mean there's a precision recall and so
on but
that's good so in terms of documentation
here this
documentation page presumably has to get
updated i mean i don't know what all
these
not that much because at the same time
it would just work better i see okay
and i believe that after this version
text case can doesn't have to be touched
for a while
uh i think it's gonna be you know
diminishing return from
from now on what about proper names
uh i think that's it's yes okay there
was this
i forgot person right i understand but
that's
notable person i'm asking for i've got
this list
of yeah i've got this you know this
random thing i want to know all the
people who are mentioned
in this news report let's say yeah
i think
i mean to me or something okay to me
there are tagging
you know there should be things in here
people
uh you know companies organizations
products
those are three types of things whose
names can be kind of funky
and which i guess can be
deduced from context and the you know
those are pretty classic
entity extraction types of things but
they're different from what we're doing
here because here
these you know these entity extractions
are tied to ultimately
our curated knowledge base which is why
we can get higher quality
but you know the number of named pulsars
in the world
is some fixed set the number of named
products in the world is not a fixed set
am i making sense you know is
is when i say i don't know
uh pink chameleon is that the name of a
product
or is that a description of some you
know
animal that's you know some organism
that's hanging out in
wherever and you know in some some
field of some kind of flowers or
something you know what i'm saying
so you know in other words how do we
tell if pink chameleon is a product name
or whether it's something different and
what have we done on that
yeah what's the answer is jerome here
can he speak to that
so jerome i think i should ping him i
think he
got something but otherwise to answer
the person like check this given name
sir name i found them
this person given that no but that's not
that's okay but
that's not good enough okay that's not
good enough that's based on our curated
knowledge base
right so that's we we do a good job
of giving names that we know about
do you understand what i'm saying that
from the context of text
you can know about even given names that
we don't know about
right in other words if it says um
you know ms blah blah blah
you know name will work for the one we
don't know about i mean
it's not a fixed list okay all right it
will work
actually you could try a mister and you
put some random name i'm pretty sure
text kids
should get it i never tried it so might
be wrong but
let's try it um i would bet that it
works
okay mr uh coffee
bean
uh had coffee
with ms uh
okay you made it harder because coffee
bean is also something else but yeah
i don't know i know i know i know with
ms
um um you know
alexis smith okay we'll make it easy
though
okay all right so now what what do i say
here
text cases and either given name or
surname
but that's not good enough i want
complete person name that's that's
obvious that's the thing that we're
going to need
hmm right i don't see that i know
i know i i know i know this is what i've
been saying for ages this is something
we need
ah what's happening well this is the
prototype build so i don't know whether
that's
whether that's some is this is this in
the prototype build what's the story
with this
this is was there before so it's in the
it's in the regular build uh
the new version the new version is not
yet deployed but i mean
it doesn't matter for for surname okay
but i'm telling you this isn't what we
want
right i've been saying this for ages we
need something which is complete name
that's what people are going to need and
we've also been talking about for ages
having a symbolic structure that
represents you know
a person with names and honorifics and
all that kind of thing yeah
i think and this is the place where we
should
put where we should be originally person
was exactly what you described
so uh actually
okay that's too bad jerome jeremy's not
there because he would where is john
he's lester's being here so where is he
i don't know i think he's
he must be lost somewhere
i think yeah person originally
was exactly what you talked about so i
think i think
i think what happened well what happened
to it
i don't say something wrong but i think
it's still
oh that was good i'm impressed
good work
all right so let's see how i say person
here
a little weird
no that was a little unconvincing yeah i
think person is exactly every every
every person it's not okay but that's
just wrong
yeah yeah yeah but anyway yeah
right but so that's what we need i mean
people products
organizations those are categories that
we need
which go beyond you know i mean these
are things that we are uniquely in a
position to do
and we're doing them and that's great
but that doesn't get us off the hook for
these other things
products that would be the one to focus
then because in company
no no no people names i'm telling you
names are really important
of course but as well what's that
you said product as well i did i said
people
products organizations yeah all three
are you know things people want and
they're complicated because their names
can be very weird
yeah all three of those i mean you know
i don't know whether we are off the hook
for you know stage names and stuff like
this
perhaps we are
good
okay by the way somebody
flippy is commenting about onyx yes we
uh we have lots of support for onyx
um and in fact we've contributed to onyx
and it's yes we're we're
we're very much on top of onyx although
it's not a panacea
doesn't solve all problems um
uh let's see
ethan is saying there's no entity
recognition text cases yeah of course
there's entity recognition that's what
we're
that's that's exactly what we're doing
here but but the when
that some things are actual entities
right
um yeah you can put interpretability i
forgot the option
right but i mean that then then that is
actual entities which we can
canonicalize but if we are talking about
you know a person's name including all
possible fictional people
um you know that's not something for
which we have entities
the whole idea there which we've never
built because we've never had a way to
get this
into the system is to have
a uh you know a person symbolic wrapper
that contains you know uh different
components of name etc etc etc
and that's something that that was what
we hoped we were going to build
you know out of things like text cases
um
so anyway okay all right i think we're
um
uh very much out of time here so
let's see anything else we want to talk
about here onyx import export
um yeah just some updates i don't think
that's too much to talk
remote training very
cool stuff that simultaneous are doing
which is i mean julio can speak about it
right it's related to the progress
monitor
ammonization and something to make it
work with remote process
and uh yeah do you want to say something
julio
yeah we are basically trying i mean the
the remote process part is
i'm working with jesse and we are
experimenting solutions to basically
have the
every function that uses the new
progress framework
will be able to report to the client so
you can basically recreate the same
progress indicator that you see
when you call the function locally you
should be able to recreate it when you
call it from the remote
batch submission but wait a minute in
remote batch submit i mean a gui
is not i mean you can't have a gui
because the thing is running as a batch
job
it's true but you have a batch uh object
and you then can query it and you can
say oh actually the dynamic progress of
this wow
that's pretty space space age that's
that
i didn't want to mention it because it's
it's we we have ideas we are
implementing the ideas but i think
they're sound
right so in other words you can get a
snapshot update you can say
now get me an update and perhaps you can
run it as a dynamic where it's
it's it's is already something which i
think is called dynamic
uh status and that's telling you you
know
like uh how many operations i've done
like
i think if you run it on amazon like
what is working what is what is already
done and we want to do something
similar to to the progress so when you
say
give me the dynamic progress that's
printed dynamic cell
that we are in charge of updating i mean
it would not be as nappy as the local
one of course
because it's a network operation but
maybe i don't know you get a refresh
like a bar that takes every
few seconds that's still better than
nothing
i'm sure this is modeled after what
happens with remote uh
batch map submit which has a pretty nice
mechanism
exactly oh yeah i was talking about that
yeah we want to do something like that
for uh for the progress uh
the the progress bar and the the grids
and everything so in principle
if we managed to pull this off you will
be able to see the same
training grid that you see for the train
locally
just with a bit slower tick of updating
that's really nice yeah that's really
nice
that's good so that's that's the goal
let's see yeah and
this i think is a super important
project because many have been
asked you know how can we train remotely
and we say well you can use the script
but i'm not very happy because i say
well i have this all nice front hand and
if i have to do everything with command
line what's the point
uh whereas with all these tools it's
gonna be not exactly like training
locally but
very close you know similar experience
okay so there's a number of comments on
our text chat uh
lou is asking about uh using text cases
and giving feedback about it
how to contact the team the best way to
do that is to
join the beta program um because there's
a whole mechanism there for
interacting with upcoming um
developments uh and
i'm sorry the the the the poor ceo
doesn't know how you do that but i'm
sure there's a i'm sure it's not too
hard and maybe somebody can
can put that on a chat how to do that
um ethan is commenting
wouldn't persons be like a person be
like an abstract entity class yes in
principle except we don't really have a
notion of an abstract entity well
we have entity classes that are
constructed for things like database
schemas
um um kind of i think it will be more
like molecule
because i think that a person is you
know
you can think about it like there's
different
confirmations of a person or something
it's like the same person but they can
have different names and they can have
you know different honorifics and they
can have all kinds of
all kinds of different things i think
it's a slightly i think it's a different
kind of concept
uh ethan is commenting on wanting remote
net
train and the batch submit
is too expensive um i mean i think
that's a question of
of that's for cloud providers i mean so
the basic point is
if i'm understanding correctly is the
basic point is you want to run it on
your own local machines i don't know
okay so why is that difficult i mean
can't you just use remote evaluate of
net train
to do that uh on your local
remote machines so to speak does anybody
know is there a problem with that i mean
so there's a question then
of if you say remote evaluative net
train do you get
the um uh progress monitoring coming
back to your local system and so on
yeah currently not no right so that's
the question is whether remote evaluate
can pass back progress monitoring that's
a that seems like a more general
remote evaluate framework question but
this is exactly
this is why we want to take up this this
progress thing
for the remote batch submit we want to
take a look at the progress framework
level
so i guess this is an another project
framework
sorry framework progress framework
project one thing i don't know i've
actually never used remote to
evaluate if it does return something
that you can query
or you just need to know it just remote
evaluates the blocking
thing there's another version remote
submit
uh that i think is ready um which does
the you know returns a task object
okay okay uh this will need design then
yeah
right so ethan is commenting on the on
the whole
uh you know the flow of money for batch
submits stuff
yes we know it is not as clean as it
might be um
that is more of a business problem which
is getting worked on
very actively um i mean it's a it's a
multi-company business issue
and yes uh hopefully this will be solved
in a good way
um unfortunately it's not something
solely under our control so to speak
um the uh yeah
i mean that's that's just
i i think actually well maybe it's not
yet announced what exactly
one part of that i know is is um is
coming
in the fairly near future um i think
it's technically
basically ready um
okay well we should wrap this up uh it
looks like we still have more things to
go over
or um and we have several things to come
back to here
um
yeah there was not i mean this little
thing you know new activation function
[Music]
link to a new library the one i don't
think there's big design
not much design left huh
besides you know missing value synthesis
yeah so so i mean this comment from
ethan about um
uh remote batch submits and license
entitlements and so on somebody should
pass us on to
jesse just to make sure that the things
we're planning will actually satisfy
what
is being talked about here okay i can do
that
jesse friedman yes okay
the um
perkins is asking about tpu support i i
assume that that's available through
the mechanisms we have i mean mxnet
supports that stuff yes
uh tpu i don't think i think it's just
for tensorflow
i see so so okay so you have to
output it as onyx and hope that the
things actually are consistent which
they're probably not
it's for training so onyx wouldn't be so
useful here
uh what about for the net architecture
i mean to train a net since we don't
have tensorflow
i don't think you can use tpu fair
enough that's
basically it huh
i mean that's a trade name of of a
particular species of
of um uh of thing
all right okay we should wrap up here
thanks everybody
and uh thanks to folks on the live
stream